all right this is the big story singer
Taylor Swift is slamming music executive
Scooter Braun after he acquired the
record company that owned her music the
deal was worth 300 million dollars
Braun's Ithaca Holdings is buying big
machine Label Group which released
Taylor Swift's first six albums Swift
called it her worst case scenario
yesterday in a tumblr post which says
she is sad and quote grossed out that
Braun now has the rights to her entire
catalogue so if accuses Braun of putting
her through years of incessant
manipulative bully
she says Scott Borchetta the head of Big
Machine Records was aware but in
response Sunday night Borchetta says he
certainly never saw Swift cry about
Braun porchetta also claims Swift had
every chance in the world to own her
music including one offer to immediately
own her masters upon resigning with the
label Swift said I was given an
opportunity to sign back up to Big
Machine Records and earn one album back
at a time one for every new one I turned
in she declined that offer leaving last
year for a deferred music label CBS News
reached out to Braun for comment and he
pointed to or said as statements she
said he said they said listen Taylor
dropped that bombshell and they both
responded really with guns blazing Scott
Borchetta released a very detailed
statement about his documentation with
Taylor going back and forth which i
think is very interesting and very
telling
Scooter Braun has also weighed weight
and so is screwed a Braun's wife so has
Justin Bieber so there's a lot of
conversation about you know one of the
things that she says that in the reason
why she posted on tumblr she wants young
artists people who are trying to break
into the music industry to understand
the contracts that they're signing the
creative output that these artists have
their own there's a tendency to give
away a lot at the beginning just to get
that signing to quote Prince yes some 20
odd years ago if you don't own your
masters your master owns you
the one thing there's a musician you
there's a tendency to not have much
money when you're trying to make it and
then if someone shows up and says here's
a chunk of change
we just want all the music
under the beat and the Beatles didn't
own a lot of their master they got they
got so Michael Jackson into them but I
think both Borchetta and scooter feel
very maligned by what Taylor is saying
and they say that they can back up and
dispute all of the things that she's
saying there's also some history to with
Taylor how she said some things in the
past that people have questioned it
sides to every story about Gale that
Taylor Swift is still a very wealthy
yeah music artist and I can give you
names Anthony Otis Blackwell TLC went
bankrupt because they didn't own Little
Richard said that you know he will go
bankrupt if we don't go to that Weber
show we're right back